-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You made it. You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm former "Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
host, Jimmy Fallon.
Nice to see you.
Well, guys, this was exciting.
Last night was the
64th Annual Grammy Awards.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think it was
a good night overall,
because nobody's watching
the uncensored Japanese version
on Twitter,
and that's a good thing.
That's right --
it was the 64th Grammy Awards,
which means it's been 64 years
of parents watching like,
"Who leaves the house
dressed like that?
You don't dress like..."
Yeah, it was a fun night.
Hours and hours of musicians
performing for free
or, as that's also known,
Spotify.
Hey!
Trevor, you could have
had that one.
-Yeah.
-Let's switch gears.
I saw that Sarah Palin
has announced
that she is running
for Congress in Alaska,
which is --
[ Audience groans ]
Which is good news
for Republicans
and great news for Democrats.
You know, for someone who could
see Russia from her house,
she should have known years ago
what Putin was up to,
don't you think?
Well, I read that thanks to
the ongoing bird-flu outbreak,
the cost of eggs is surging
in grocery stores
across the country.
You'll know things are bad when
kids spend
Easter dyeing eggbeaters.
And that's not the only problem
the bird flu is causing.
Apparently, Costco is facing
supply shortages
of its rotisserie chickens.
And now I'm wondering,
what came first?
The chicken shortage
or the egg shortage?
[ Laughter ]
I missed you guys. I really did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I missed you.
Thank you.
Well, that's right --
Costco is running low,
which means
they're down to roughly
10 billion rotisserie chickens.
They give you one on the way in.
You're like,
"Oh, I don't even want --"
"Just take three. Just --"
"Okay."
Yeah, it turns out bird flu
has been spreading quickly
because some of
the chickens have been using
fake vaccine cards.
Isn't that unbelievable?
What?!
Yeah, get this -- a man in
Germany is in trouble
after he got
90 COVID vaccine shots
so that he could sell
forged vaccine cards.
90 doses.
That guy could eat fried bat
for dinner and be fine.
And this is annoying.
Even after 90 doses,
the CDC says he'll probably need
another booster
in about four months.
And, finally, a Supreme Court
justice in Sweden
has been fined after she was
caught shoplifting meatballs.
If she does it again,
she'll be sentenced to
six months living in an IKEA.
We have a great show, everybody.